Speaker 1: Let's speak to people in the audience.
Last week's calls were fascinating. Some of the
better calls we've had. Let's see if we can keep
the streak going. We take calls via discord. You
can find our discord at David Pakman dot com slash
discord. It's free. Completely and totally free.
Let's start today with Jude from
Canada. Jude, welcome. What's going on?
Speaker 2: Hey, David. I was just wondering
what you thought about Canada's role in the
Ukraine Russia conflict.
Speaker 3: And then I was
also wondering if you think Canada.
Speaker 2: Will be soon to follow
with the U.S. recession.
Speaker 1: So my understanding
in terms of Canada's involvement is Canada has
provided some training primarily and maybe some
arms to Ukrainians. And is it through Poland
that they've done it? I apologize if I don't
have all the facts in front of me.
Speaker 2: Yeah. I believe that's it.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, I don't find anything
particularly shocking nor remarkable in the
positive or negative. I mean, it seems
that the vast majority of Canadians
similarly interpret this as an aggression
act, an invasion act by Russia.
They are sympathetic to the Ukrainian cause.
And I mean, is there something more specific
you wanted me to react to? It seems sort of
like a normal response, I guess I would say.
Speaker 2: No, that would that
would be that would be. I was
more wondering about the recession question.
Speaker 1: I have no idea. I mean, again, I don't
it's it really doesn't seem to me that the U.S. is
in a recession. I know that there's this technical
when there's two consecutive quarters of
GDP shrinkage, we are in a recession. But
the last GDP reduction from last quarter was
so small. And when you look at the details,
it's a result of decreased government spending,
decreased inventories partially from people buying
so much stuff. It's just hard to look at
that and being at nearly full employment
and the stock market seemingly on the up
and up at least over the last half month
or so and say this is clearly a recession. So
never mind, is Canada heading to a recession?
I don't even know that the U.S. is in one.
Speaker 2: Okay. Interesting. Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right. Jude from Canada, thank
you so much for the call. I appreciate it